l'accueil a été plus que chaleureux
l'admirent poutine qui a la vilaine
habitude de faire attendre ses invités
cette fois est arrivé à l'avant ce
dessin de courtoisie typiquement russe
kim jong-un a été reçue au champagne et
au caviar
puis le leader nord coréen a remercié
son hôte en lui offrant un immense sabre
et a chuté qu'il fut une époque où
c'était l' arme de choix
la question nucléaire aura évidemment
été au coeur de ce premier tête à tête
mais ne laisse deux heures à huis clos
avec un terreau très jeune et on croire
il faut adapter nos relations
traditionnelles aux exigences de ce
nouveau siècle déclaré kim jong-un
l'admirent poutine étaient attentifs ils
profitent au maximum de l'impasse entre
pyongyang et washington pour s'insérer
dans un dossier où son rival dans
l'autre homme avait pris l'initiative
mais qui semble aujourd'hui vouée à
l'échec
la résolution de la crise passera par le
droit international et non par la loi du
plus fort a prévenu le président en
conférence de prefuse d'or nos profs
l'avenir poutine semble avoir beaucoup
mieux saisi tempérament de kim jong-un
que dans notre choix dont l'ultimatum
pour le démantèlement du programme
nucléaire nord coréen a fait dérailler
les négociations hanoi enfilera les tirs
sont nombreux je ne suis pas bien kim
est venu chercher l'appui de la russie
pour faire contrepoids à la position
américaine de cet expert et il a bien
joué ses cartes l'admirent poutine s'est
engagé à servir d'interlocuteur pour
expliquer à washington les attentes de
la corée du nord
quand les démocrates celle ci veut des
garanties pour sa sécurité sa
souveraineté expliqué poutine et ces
garanties ne peuvent se limiter à la
seule parole des états unis ce qui
laisse entendre qu'il pourrait aussi
faire appel à la chine la corée du sud
et au japon
pour revenir à une approche
multilatérale sans laquelle il sera
selon lui impossible de désarmer la
corée du nord et obtenir la levée des
sanctions
ce premier sommet aura été un succès non
pas pour sa substance mais son symbole
kim jong-un a peut-être
vdans son vieil allié de la guerre
froide quelqu'un qui plaidera sa cause
auprès de la communauté internationale
poutine n'a rien à perdre c'est pour lui
retrouvé sa voix la levée des sanctions
est aussi essentiel pour ses avancées
commerciales en asie
ici tu as marre altérer ce que
radio-canada moscou